how's it going reject nation Greg Alba
here it's going Andrew here Andrew
Gordon from the movie source channel
thanks for being here buddy welcome
Andrew what franchise that you just
rewatched DCE you I mean the MCU here II
watched all the MCU films recently in
preparation for infinity war and I say
not good enough Andrew now you got to
watch a supercut of all the film
okay fine one more time the twenty
minute fashion got a lot of requests for
this especially by James stake ins over
at patreon so stay against patron today
shot gonna got to you after this video
all right Andrew you ready I'm ready
Greg MCU exchange this is the channel
people Marvel newsdesk
that's cool
the idea was to bring together a group
of remarkable people this is pretty cool
star-lord Lucy the road to infinity war
wow this is really serious
you know supposed to be too [ __ ] to
edit
the universe
just phase one yeah the Avengers main
villain me to be it's the unspoken truth
of humanity that you crave subjugation
I've seen the true power of Tesla
bloob even the sky
[Music]
by a transformers 3 ha ha meets fast and
furious Wow we've come a long way Shoni
Edward Norton footage yeah Phil show
this movie night and the I hate that
Captain America soon from The Avengers
it's the only suit as I hate
how desperate you call us up selasa
creatures yeah oh so what are we a team
no no we're a chemical mixture that
makes chaos
as Legolas there's no wrong there is no
version of this where you come out
oh yeah the roots peach excited I was
the first time at some that tracking
start
[Music]
oh great editing that's great editing
PTSD time wow this must have taken some
serious storyboarding nothing's been the
same system you the experience these men
their ovaries to kick swing him guns
aliens of inventions
[Music]
didn't you a new structural and
compositional analysis in scepter is
alien the jewel appears to be a
protective housing for something inside
something my inhalation the gym good
guess what's it look like
like it's thinking they just don't like
infinity or is this not a key to
creating mantra I see you super fun
I've seen colder
it's your time
what is this please this feels weird
this feels wrong man created the Avenger
[Music]
protect the world that's courtesy half
the Avengers exchange Winter Soldier
whether or not he is nothing why we
fight so we can end the fight so we get
to go home every time someone tries to
win a war before it starts innocent
people die every to scratch the surface
[Music]
I was on the trailer I was it ultra
listen he will in Italy and he's in pain
but that pain will roll
so he must be the storm oh I saw
something I would find here it's a car I
can fight it there though this is piece
of my time Oh John thanks monster what's
wrong this isn't just about me it's
about whether he's right I'm sick of
watching people pay for our mistake
this is exactly
yeah definitely like that this is like
really well
[Music]
phase three might be my favorite phases
yeah it's getting there it's probably
there for me too we need to be put in
check whatever form that taken game and
if we come to a decision
and you were tired if we sign this mr.
raft
[Music]
yeah but the difference of idealism
that's what's one of the caps just pain
begin accepting new patients were bound
in this room veteran like widow gets a
lot of haircuts she does say winter
soldiers my favorite letters like to be
doing
it's so crazy your judgments can spider
you trying to keep you from turning
Pinterest good that one yeah this really
this franchise really has been led by
Iron Man huh yeah yeah it's a Damon
congratulations criminal
reach out
so man now
they've gone their separate ways perhaps
for the first movie we get into a
situation like this again what happens
then
you'll come back
really sure I am
it's not even Josh Brolin's Damian
Poitier he was in Captain America Civil
War this actor oh really
yeah he's the one drop it hood I dropped
these long black widow sheets and that's
that's the actor playing Bannos hear
that that's Josh Brolin that's Guardian
and that's a alyson hannigan husband
really do this trailer myself best MCU
villain ever reality star force infinite
destruction while the other relics often
appears elsewhere we got our
introduction of the Infinity stones or
the tongue really about them going to
stink damn [ __ ] my father bought finally
[Music]
no consequences strange no price to pay
dude he's a good and he's gonna be a
good nose
star-lord we're going to Power Stone
I trust you did she better be learner
killed tell me what this was
cuz I'm guessing it's some kind of
weapon for creation system damn it's
crazy to know how like well strategize
this franchise
I noticed that when I was relaunch
everything they really set things up oxy
no hope of life
you know there's not wise to keep two
Infinity stones so close together
you know that right you've seen what it
does to people falling into the hands of
the risk is far greater if you do
nothing it's shipped to the over our
heads right now we'd never even know how
there is strength in whites challenge
challenge
[Music]
[Music]
do it killing nebula oh yeah spider-man
I can't wait for that same do our best
o get killed walk it off
to wipe out half the universe against
all the Infinity stones with the snap of
his fingers
we got one advantage he's coming to us
once so that's what we use talk about
let's plan of yours I think it's good
except it sucks
Bellavia be epic and then to be reminded
what real
watch my French doesn't hurt this could
be putting it off and depressing [ __ ]
do you think we can bust arms do it on
longer David honest is something one
considers for the balance
but this
for instance
God roses
Charles Villanueva
nice job Charles great job dude sure
it's not Charles Xavier
it's the watchman watching it Stanley I
thought I have the same setup and I had
it I've seen the people at sick oh that
was she's gonna kill thanos I told you
man
so Stan humans are on they think order
in chaos are somehow opposites city try
to control what won't great shadows
great slim fit it's a privilege to be
among Scottie
normalise today it's given us
it has given us a chance
I'm surrounded
and will be great
intelligence sacrifice never wears that
helmet i'ma protect
I lost every breath I'd rather be a good
man
did this dream anything yeah she does
change her hair a little bit how much
for these
the only thing we have injuries are
yours maybe more so than you definitely
soon they haven't let me down which is
why I came in under the promise yes if
you need me I'll be loose you do that
together too
that's getting out of emotional
[Music]
Oh get your ass a good match go
ready Wow
the one song we remember from the MC Wow
that was an epic ass - pretty cut yeah
it was really cool especially if you
haven't like caught up on rewatching the
movies a cast jumbles it all back for
you so that's good I mean yes a lot so
cool dude incredible editing job just to
break down the the Edit really quick
he's essentially just breaking down the
phases and a really fluid notion and
sometimes he cuts back from like
something that might be foreshadowed
from an earlier movie or something it's
gonna be said in a later film and it
goes back to an earlier one and I
thought that was really cool
showing just how everything's even
linked in it even made me appreciate
some stuff that like Ultron even said if
we just attach I visited for age of
Ultron and II the portray Ultron kinda
let me down but then just seeing the few
lines that they feature here you're like
ah maybe hey Ultron lines are very
specifically tuned for this infinity war
setup that I didn't even realize I mean
it might just be like a coincidence of
the line also of you know whenever
you're winning or I forget something
about God there was a stone at you but I
thought that's like a great line for
especially setting up all these Infinity
stones and whatnot I love how this is
like setting up like the world and the
despair and the chaos but then the
ending note of it the reasoning and the
belief and and and the feeling of
heroism in the last like two to three
minutes of this edit because this whole
time it's kind of like - really dark and
you're feeling like the weight in the
crappity of the situation it's like
you're introducing the characters that
situational sup in the last two to three
minutes it's like oh yeah the the
personal motivations for all these
individuals who have had to rise up
against really hard odds and why that
are doing this brings you back to this
is why we're so invested in the MCU
because we love the [ __ ] out of these
characters more than just a plot line so
yeah really well done really well I love
to how we started off like showing each
of the characters struggles and then
like you know yeah chronologically
showing the storyline a little bit and
then building it up like you said
showing all these characters motivations
and
we love these characters so much and
then some really sick action action
sequences and then like you said I love
how he just cut from other lines and
other films to match what we were seeing
you know what he had was from another
film and just he really did a great job
of matching those editing points because
like a lot of the dialogue just really
worked with what was visually being
shown absolutely watching Thanos like as
Thor said like playing them as chess
pieces like you really get to see that a
lot in this whole outline because you
see again that Thanos has been watching
this whole time have been taking note of
where all the stones are obviously he
hasn't done anything himself but with
that Thoth from what rewatching this I'm
like you know what the ancient one and
Odin could be big reasons why he never
tried to invade earth and triangle a few
stones now that they have died maybe
earth is now for the taking a little
more width so I mean just watch him like
that that's I got a lot of those kind of
vibes how famous is just like waiting
for the perfect time to go after that it
actually makes me appreciate the MCU
even more because they have a plan yeah
like you see that this plans been set up
from the very beginning we all know that
it's the clever subtle ways of doing it
sometimes are a little bit more forward
about it then subtle however like no one
does it like the MCU as well as they do
other franchises can be like way too
obvious of like dude just stick to your
freakin one it would be minor man - yeah
something like that
Iron Man choose the only one that kind
of got carried away and Zeb's parting up
setting up yeah and parts of age of
Ultron as well but in terms of like
building up to the Infinity stones and
building up to Thanos this franchise is
like sprinkling in it throughout and
it's been in front of us the entire time
yeah so if you're not a comic book
reader going back and just watching the
supercut makes you go wow infinity war
is the culmination and you know and just
add your point they do things in their
films like lines wise or visual images
where they show you or say something
that's going to happen in the future for
instance an Ironman went for Terrence
Howard and had on Cheetos Jim Rhodes he
says whiplash one what is it whiplash as
the character as the villain we see an
Iron Man - we've seen Captain America
the Winter Soldier we see agent Sitwell
saying you Bruce Banner Stephen strange
she's talking about Stephen strange
pictures of economy and also Bucky three
different films where he's had captio
which tells me one day he'll
Captain America but again they do these
little cell things or right in your face
things where it doesn't hurt that the
current storyline right but they do a
subtle way of when it does happen in the
future like ah they set that up they
sprinkled it like later they put a
little seed in the ground and then it
just blossomed into a beautiful flower
and like they're good about that stuff
even continuity wise we pointed out
something when we watch spider-man
homecoming no we're not going to talk
about that years later they screwed that
up but we are gonna talk about that
black eye when he had that black and
blue I like that was the exact same spot
that Bucky put the bat mark they just do
such a good job of paying attention
these little integral things those
little things matter to me like we're
black and a blue mark is and I just love
how much the filmmakers Kevin Feige
LaRussa brothers all them I just love
how much that they put so much care and
effort into you know yes universe I
literally just finished reading the
Infinity Gauntlet comic book there's way
more characters a lot more things that
play in it's not gonna be accurate to
the Congo all I care about is they keep
the essence of Thanos know you've got to
be comic-book accurate yeah I'm just
gonna keep the essence of the characters
nebula does play a big part in the
finale of that comic book I'm kind of
hoping that they do utilize her in
taking on Thanos I think like they're
probably gonna lose in this one course
and then because there's a part to this
yeah there's a part two to this which
will have a spoiler in its title so
we're waiting on that Captain Marvel is
gonna come to save the day it's gonna be
a it's gonna be a setup for them to have
a victory in Avengers 4 I am hoping that
they do get a utilize nebula in a better
way because I'm not a big fan of her
right now and in terms of how she's been
portrayed in the movies in terms of like
comic-book accuracy I'm hoping that
nebula is gonna play a part of helping
take down Thanos especially because her
and Gamora arguably have the more
personal vendetta with Thanos out of
everyone as well as the other you know
the black order rep aneema
Corvus glaive Proxima midnight and yeah
well I'm talking about but ya know in
terms of the Avengers yeah it's really
the personal yes many children but yes
no I agree with you and again I'm not
gonna say the films a bust if it doesn't
happen in the fourth one but I
personally from the story that and I do
watch and guardians of the galaxy vol 2
and what we just heard in that clip
during nebula like how fan O's ripped
off body parts of news whenever she lost
to Gamora I want to see her be the one
who put
the final killing into Thanos in the
fourth man when that happened personally
that's what I would like to see just
from you know Thanos not ever believing
that she was her equal to Gamora stay
extinct amours her favorite daughter
there's a lot of personal vendetta from
not only obviously Gamora cuz she lost
her family too she's got a lot that to
hate pianos for but I mean stop her body
parts and was replacing them so like
she's got the ultimate motivation of her
venture and who at least for me who I
want to see ultimately no man the one
with the most personal issue and then
the comic where she does manage to like
actually take the Infinity Gauntlet from
him and which is a really cool moment in
the comic book itself I don't think it's
gonna go down that path in the movie of
course the Barbie Black Widow yeah right
superbee Wong I'm really excited for
this and this super cut is I think is
amazing because it's edited so well and
communicates all three phases so well
enough to the point where if you don't
have time to binge you can just watch
this 20 minute video and you'll be all
caught up yeah and also too I mean you
you made a point you said the Marvel 3
or mock phase 3 is your favorite phase
so far I think from a villains
perspective I beyond have to agree with
that perspective like in my opinion the
villains of Marvel phase 3 are
outstanding much better they really care
longer alter yeah Apella Zemo Captain
America when her soldiers needs to be
like people's favorite movies some of
the phase might have arguably a better
installment but I think in terms of a
whole I think age 3 hasn't had a misstep
ya know and except for how I feel about
gardens ago I mean I'd say my only issue
with that is what he did with ego going
on
star-lord but that's that's a different
discussion but no I agree with you for
the most part phase 3 has been just
about perfect and I rewatched tour
Ragnarok even the other day the Hat film
is so freakin brilliant like the 80s
vibe theme and they're the 80 synthetic
music the comedic tone like it really
almost feels like a rebooted franchise
in general but phase 3 has been great
and again I just love how this whole
thing just captures everything like in
in 20 minutes and just like really packs
it all into something that's very
organic epic and awesome visually
absolutely absolutely well dude this was
a great edit thank you to the channel
MC you exchange guys you should
subscribe to them I don't know why they
only have 20 K followers they should
have more and hey page from the day shop
for James Stegen 's Stegen ater my man
all the way in that boring ass state you
live in dude you got to get out of there
come to LA it's very cheap to live here
you know
get off yeah it's so much more
affordable that we're here get off the
cigarettes man you're gonna die early
you're a patronage act you've been a
loyal follower I want you to keep
staying around should we tell the
audience that Marlboro is sponsoring the
Marlboro sponsoring us guys don't smoke
cigarettes don't smoke cigarettes though
that's what they wanted me to
communicate see James if you die early
we're gonna lose your pledge on patreon
and we can't afford to lose that
seriously tight times in the economy of
YouTube so please don't be selfish James
yeah and if you if you quit smoking
cigarettes that money can go towards
increase you apply jewelry Jackson it's
all about preserving us hey I'll see you
hang out later buddy guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell so subscribe
buttons means something and check us out
on page around full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is become a
patronage act today people
you